we've had a look at a variety of
different properties and I've tried to
group them in categories the very first
one was about chords I should say
categories that somewhat overlap the
first ones about chords then we looked
at angles what are the kinds of things
have we looked at within circles most
recently we looked at we looked at
particular kinds of quadrilaterals do
you remember that what do we call a
quadrilateral when it's all on the
circumference we call a cyclic
quadrilateral very good so now we're
moving into tangents now if you have a
look at these three I've got them on the
left of the right just because I wanted
I want the projective space it's quite
obvious that these first two have to do
with tangents by the way we're going to
fill these in in a second these mystery
words the last property doesn't look
like it has anything to do with tangents
because this word here that's the blank
it's not tangent so what is this has to
do with anything well that will emerge
once we get to it okay so for starters
we're going to win a prove these very
briefly but in order to know what we're
proving well we should draw these things
and then we'll know what this property
is and then we can set out to actually
prove it
deductively so have a look at the first
one tangents or a tangent is something
to the radius at the point of contact
all right what that means is we all know
what a tangent is a tangent just touches
hence the name just touches a circle at
a single point
we call that unimaginably the point of
contact okay so go ahead draw yourself a
circle draw a tangent any tangent that
you like and then at the point where
that tangent intersects with the circle
at that point of contact I'd like you to
draw the radius can you go ahead and do
that for me
mercifully this is a fairly simple
diagram you can see mine over on the
right hand side there there's my tangent
you can draw yours anywhere that you
like I put in the center so that now
it's very straightforward to draw in the
radius so when you draw that radius no
matter how big your circle is no matter
where you have placed your tangent
you should see what's the relationship
between the tangent and the radius at
the point of contact they sure look like
they're at right angles don't they
now of course it's not enough to just
say they look like they're at right
angles we want to prove that this is the
case as with most geometry proofs
there's a variety of different ways to
do this but this way our value to show
you is one of my favorites okay
don't worry too much about all of this
fluff on the left hand side it's just
what I had to put into decimals to make
these new shapes I want you to observe
what's going on as we did with calculus
our way of understanding tangents often
starts with understanding a simpler
shape namely a secant right because the
tangents sort of like a special version
of a secant it's the what happens in
secant when it doesn't cut twice when it
cuts once so once you have a look at
this shape here with me I've got a
secret that can move up and down okay
like whoops there we go well why so much
lag sorry I've just got bad at that
better there we go okay so you can see
there's my orange secant right and as I
move the secant up and down you can see
the situation changing no big deal okay
as you can see if I moved it to there my
radius unfortunately my radii they
disappeared just because of the way that
I've set up these equations but you can
see it's clearly still where it is just
like ours is in fact I can even draw it
right now where's the center somewhere
like here there's a situation got our
right angle okay is that makes sense
what I want you to notice is as I go
back to the secant I want you to notice
the angle that sort of corresponds is
because the ends are all moving about
what is the angle and where is it so
watch what happens when I move it if I
can aim properly there we go
okay hi this is mr. said to me I got
pretty question this angle here was
right beside where I intersect with this
line right so what that corresponds to
this angle here corresponds to get rid
of it this angle over here I'm going to
give it a name I'm going to call it feet
up and on your diagram which let's just
pause it here we're not going to move it
around for the next component let's just
create this diagram and name that angle
over there seed up let's just call it
that and then see how we can reason out
what's going on okay
this angle theta is the able form
between the radius and the secant not
the radius in the tangent because it's
not a tangent yet but the radius and the
secant okay so you can clearly see they
correspond to each other their own
connected ideas right so where can I go
from here I want to prove that when this
becomes let me see it becomes a tangent
this line or this angle rather should be
or if it's perpendicular like we're
suggesting this angle should become 90
degrees right which sort of intuitively
I said I wasn't going to move it I'm
gonna have to get it back to the exact
spot again it's not intuitive as um we
get wider wider wider you can see that
angle theta is moving down over there
it's close to a straight angle do you
see that close to 180 and then as I
bring it down you can see it gets closer
and closer to that 90 look there we go
closer and closer to a right angle there
okay
what was it one point three five or
something so what was yeah awesome okay
so I want to try and get to this I want
to show that this is going to become 90
degrees what it starts to reason through
it
adjacent to theta is on this straight
angle another angle inside the circle
what's the size of this angle that's not
too hard to see so that's 180 minus
there but because of the way we've
constructed this diagram you notice that
we have radii here right so what kind of
triangle is this triangle inside so
isosceles which means that if that angle
over there is 180 minus theta then this
one over here
is also under Nehemiah theta okay now
once you've got two angles in a triangle
you also know the third angle this takes
a little bit of thought what's this
thing we're going to be equal to
remember we want all three of these
angles to add up to 180 degrees you
agree now look I've already got 180
there and then there's 100 a that's 360
so whatever I'm going to have to have
I'm going to have to subtract 180 right
you see that's what's going to happen
these guys are going to become 180 but
then I've got these pesky feeders
hanging around I want to get rid of them
because the angle sum of triangle have
no theatres and it's just got 180 so how
many feeders are they gonna have to be
here to balance it all out to theta do
you agree so that's what this angle at
the center is equal to oh and of course
just like on the opposite side we've got
theta here to the symmetrical okay so
now here comes the fun part
I'm going to borrow a bit of the
language and notation that we used in
limits I'm not actually going to do a
formal limit this is somewhat of an
informal proof but I'm going to borrow
the language so I'm going to say as this
angle is the center right and this angle
changes what happens now we want to turn
this seeker into a tangent right I wanna
take this secant into a tangent by
moving it up so I want you to pay
attention to this angle what happens to
2 theta minus 180 degrees watch it as I
get closer and closer and closer to
being a tangent look what is happening
to the size of this angle it's shrinking
in fact at the spot that I really want
this angle should not even be an angle
it should be 0 right so I'll just come
back do you see other other gears
turning in your head yet right yeah
that'll do that's close enough so what
I'm going to think about is what happens
as this angle approaches so here's what
we use our website in limits right under
the producer zero what's going on well
if 2 theta minus hundred degrees is
approaching zero this actually has a lot
like an equation doesn't it because if
this whole thing is approaching zero
what's 2 theta approaching
it must be right because this component
has to balance out with this one to give
you zero
well if true theater is approaching 180
then exactly half of that angle should
be which is kind of exactly what the
property says doesn't it right so as
this angle shrinks beam angles must
approach 90 degrees and that's it it's
informal but I hope like the logic
satisfies you like you see how we
approached it so tangent are
perpendicular to the radius at the point
of contact okay